hello everyone and welcome to the next
openal
tutorial this is video three this one is
sort of gonna
be a primer for the rest of what's to
come because all the cool stuff is about
to happen but before we can do all the
cool stuff there's a bit of leg work
in getting the sounds playing in a
looping fashion
and in a way where we can play around
with their distance
and also their direction so this
episode's more about how to set it up
to uh start playing around with all the
distance and stuff
so i'm just going to show you all the
changes that will be in the code
as of today when you see this uploaded
or whatnot
i'll put a link down below to the code
so you can check it out and there will
be a tag
video three tag if you're watching this
from the future
okay so the first thing we wanted to do
the main thing we wanted to do is we
wanted to start getting a loop
so i have included just a little bit of
a code i wrote
called a main loop it's actually in a
whole other
repo so i'll just show you that real
quick
it's pretty straightforward
it's uh i call it main loop it's a
single header
and really all it does is it's just this
one little clasp here
that allows us to add things to a loop
and then press
run and it'll loop until our run
condition is
met or fails rather in this case
so we're going to have ways to do things
on every update
and on delayed updates should we choose
to if we don't want to happen
super quick and we have some other
functions just to
support so i just added this in with
git submodules so you'll see over here
in the changes that are ready to be
staged and
committed that the main loops of modules
added and the only thing i'm using from
that
is the main loop.h
[Music]
which is right there
so this whole chunk of code is now in
here
it's about 200 lines but it's great for
starting out with a game or something
because
it's a nice way to kind of control your
program so i put that in there that way
we could start
messing with that we're also going to be
using
the windows header for keyboard presses
this of course will be a little
different on linux
or mac you can adjust you could add
whatever it is for linux and mac instead
if you're using that
but essentially the only thing we're
using here is uh
get key state and that way we can just
have some keyboard presses
so on the on our updates which
runs every
as frequently as it can basically we're
going to check for an a key press
to play that heel sound and if the heel
is already currently playing we're going
to play the fail spell
sound so that way it's going to give you
like that
you're already casting type sound sort
of akin to what world warcraft does when
you try to press the same spell when
you're already casting
so i kind of put that in there with the
heel but let's
start from the top here so i am
declaring a
boolean i guess i could have this as a
static right inside the main
just want to do it before we set this
run condition
and it does need to be static if it's
inside to make the main because
you populate this main loop with lambdas
that's just the way it works so if
you're not super familiar with lambdas
i'll put a link to a lambdas video
i did a while ago that covers pretty
much everything about them
but the basic syntax is these brackets
and then the curly brackets with your
code
and uh yeah check that video out if
you're completely new
to lambdas it should fill you in pretty
good i changed some of these file names
the sound source is now called sound
effect player
and the other one
was named his now named sound effects
library because it is essentially a
library of sounds i think it was called
sound buffer before
it still is sort of the sound buffer but
it's just a library of everything you've
loaded
so basically all you do with this is
load or unload
and there's some notes here in case
you're not sure what to do
you basically get an id back for the
loaded ones
and you can either unload with that id
or use it on the player to play
so this just helps handle those and load
or unload them because say you're going
in between levels or something
and you want to unload a bunch of sounds
you'll never use again and you want to
load up new ones
this little library allows you to do
stuff like that so it just gives you
some control over what's in memory
and our sound effects player has been
we've made it a little a little bit more
robust before it only had play
now we also have stop pause and resume
which we're not going to use yet but
they are
already built and we also have a way to
just
change the buffer to play other than
just hitting play because before you
would just have to pass a different one
but the thing is
if you're trying to pass it a different
one while was playing it'll throw an
error so you don't want to do that
and we have a way to control whether
it's looping or not if it's looping
it'll just continue to play until you
stop it
and we just have a boolean to check if
it is playing so we can call this
anytime we need to check
or any of our logic and his playing just
gets the state and returns whether the
state is playing
so it'll return true if it's played
music buffer is still about the same but
i did add a few things you can now
pause stop and resume the play so before
we only have play and update buffers
buffer stream and we can also
check if it's playing it's the same as
the sound effect one
and the sound device we added a few
things here too
basically we added the listener i just
put these defines at the top
to make it easier than so you don't have
to call the sound device.get all the
time
or don't have to type all that out you
can just type in listener
in our main for example and i did the
same thing with these loads you might
have noticed on the sound effects
library
there's just a defined sound effect load
so rather than having to type in all
this
the programmer can just type in this and
i i like doing that it's just a personal
preference really
so anyway back to our sound device i
added some
some ways to start setting the location
orientation and the master volume or the
gain
so since this is sound device basically
functions as your listener too
when you initiate a new initialize a new
sound device you also get a listener
and that's basically what hears all the
sounds or what comes out of your
speakers or your headphones
so being that this is moving towards 3d
sound we need a way to move around in
the world and orientate in the world so
that's why we have set location and set
orientation
there's some others i haven't added in
here too that open ale has
like uh we're gonna have set velocity
but uh yeah we're gonna need functions
to change all of that on the fly and we
will get to that later that'll probably
be like five or six
other core things to mention the way i'm
doing this
the music is really only made to be
played
stereo both headphones
left and right stereo sound is not made
to be positioned
we could but we'd have to make sure we
have mono sources
and then we'd have to put in all the
location stuff in this class
i'm not going to be doing that for music
because in general i think when music's
playing
you probably want it to just be in your
headphones
and you control the level manually like
in the settings
so i'm not going to be doing positional
stuff with the music although we could
we're only going to be doing it with the
sound effects so
in here i am going to have basically the
same thing that this listener has we're
going to have
location orientation and gain
and uh velocity and speed as well
and i think there's one other thing i
can't think of i'm velocity and speed
might be the same thing anyway
someone will correct me in the comments
i'm sure so
just to give you a little diagram real
quick
so basically you have like a cone
so that's like the area you hear from
but by default it's 360. so
if you don't change anything you hear in
all directions and
other sounds so these sound effects they
also have
a position and based on how far away you
are
it changes so there's some
tuning in this open al programmer's
guide
you'll see once we start setting up
distance models
there's some different ones you can you
can do the default one
is uh this al inverse distance clamped
and it seems to be like the industry
standard one
for sound distance but depending on how
like you're programming your game
you might be doing your measurements
different so you do have to play around
with this a little bit we're going to
try to keep it real simple in this
particular tutorial
but know that in this main open al
programmers guide from their website
they tell you all about it but we're
probably just going to stick with the
inverse distance clamped
in our case we might play around the
others later
and also these sounds emit in a certain
direction too
so by default they emit 360
but you can make them you can change
them to just a cone
so you can have sounds that only emit
sound in a certain direction
okay so let's go through this give it a
little demo
and uh we'll be prepared for next video
so we load up our sounds we load up the
spell sound we love
fail sound we have a player for them as
well
and we load up some music to have that
ready
so with this main loop we want to set a
run condition
we basically want to return this keep
running variable which is going to be
true
so we can have somewhere else in our
logic something that sets it to false
and that'll exit the game
add to on begin i don't have anything in
here right now
so i'm not doing any special anything
special on begin
i could do something like put a cl that
says like starting but
we're just going to leave it blank might
even just delete it
because we're not using it okay so this
add to on update
is the main thing this is just something
we're adding to
every update loop and since we're
passing in a flue a float
flute um it's the delta time
if you look at the uh add to on update
there's two versions of it
there's one that takes a float and that
is the delta time as you can see here
so it just runs through all those and
gives it the elapsed time
if you're doing one of the float ones
so it's just all programmed to have the
time ready which is
why i included it it just makes it
easier easier than typing it all out
again
so we're getting the delta time every
time and the reason for that is because
we're putting a cool down on these
sounds
uh the heel sound has a three second
cooldown
so if you you can't spam it if you could
spam it it'll just make like a
crazy sounding noise of it beginning a
million times a second
and same with this failed one so we put
a little bit of cooldown on that
as well of 0.8 seconds seemed pretty
good
and he'll have a three second seem
pretty good
and we also have some music controls
here
we can start the music by hitting p and
that's about all i put i could add some
stuff to stop it and pause it
and now another important thing with the
music playing
is we need to add to an update
the update buffer stream for the music
otherwise it's only going to play the
first
split second of it from buffering so i
put in here
on delayed update and the default delay
is a tenth of a second
so this will run every tenth of a second
if the music is played we'll update the
buffer stream so as soon as you pause it
or stop it or something it'll stop
updating the buffer stream
and then the last thing we do is we just
call run on this main loop and it will
start running all these functions in a
loop
all right so let's go ahead and give it
a go
okay looks good it's currently running
if i press a i should get the heel sound
press it before it's ready again
it gives the fail sound so if i just
spam it
uh you can't yet so you have to wait
all right and then if i press p
[Music]
tick begins and it's buffering
it's going through that update and
buffering
and it's just going to continue because
i don't have a way to stop it and
you might have noticed i didn't program
any way to quit
in here so i could just put something in
here like
i might as well
if uh get key
state q
check for this most significant bit and
we'll just say
keep running to false
so now if i stop and rebuild this i can
quit with the
q key so that way we have a way to
actually exit the program
rather than just running endlessly
okay so now if i press q it quits
because it'll exit the loop and get to
the end of the program so i'm going to
get rid of all this old
code don't need it anymore and in fact
this main loop
actually returns an integer whether it
was successful or not
or had an error so we can actually just
return it
in our case here since we're not doing
anything else
and that's going to do it for this
episode and this preparation so next
episode we are going to get into moving
these sounds around
and playing with some positions now that
we have it all in a loop
we should be able to get a little main
guy of some sort that moves around
and some sounds that can be in different
positions
i might even get a little bit of opengl
in here just for
some visuals but it should be lots of
fun so
thank you so much for watching hopefully
this was helpful and
i guess i'll see you in the next one
peace out guys
[Music]
you